à la différence de ses amis son
téléphone portable est un ancien modèle
sans accès à l'Internet
sans le savoir ça dépendence la grugeait
intérieurement
jusqu'au matin ou tout a basculé alors
qu'il se rendait à l'école
sa mère était dévastée
des parents d'adolescents a été entendu
par les législateurs de l'Utah qui ont
décidé de réglementer les fameux réseaux
sociaux responsables selon eux de bien
des mots
ainsi les réseaux sociaux comme
Instagram Facebook YouTube TikTok et
autres vont devoirifier l'âge de chacun
de leurs utilisateurs et obtenir le
consentement des parents pour l'accès en
général l'Utah impose aussi un
couvre-feu sur les réseaux sociaux de
22h30 le soir jusqu'à 6h30 le matin pour
les moins de 18 ans à moins que les
parents autorisent l'accès à leurs
enfants les responsables d'écoles jubilé
une lourde tâche qui devrait être
combattue à la source selon eux
c'est-à-dire par les entreprises de
réseaux sociaux mais aussi par les
parents eux-mêmes
mais comment vérifier l'âge des
utilisateurs la recherche de solutions
fait partie de la mission du département
du Commerce de l'Utah
car quand on parle de restreindre
l'accès des Américains à quoi que ce
soit des poursuites ne sont jamais très
loin au nom du premier amendement celui
de la liberté d'expression
les parents d'adolescents comme Lydie
n'ont pas peur de ce genre de menace
juridique
aussi les parents à attaquer devant les
tribunaux ces entreprises s'il y a des
dommages à la santé mentale de leurs
enfants par exemple
mais il y aurait des victimes
collatérales à cet accès restreint aux
réseaux sociaux Eaton vient d'avoir 18
ans influenceur autiste qui a utilisé
les réseaux sociaux pour sensibiliser
les jeunes il comptabilise un demi
milliard de visionnements de ces vidéos
qui concernent entre autres les arts
martiaux dont il est un des champions du
monde
les réseaux sociaux dit-il peuvent
apporter du positif dans la vie des
jeunes
sa mère qui s'occupe du marketing des
plateformes de son fils et qui ont fait
un gagne-pain est inquiète à cause de
toutes ces lois qui resteraient l'accès
sur Internet
sera de bannir complètement certains
réseaux en Utah après l'arcansas et la
Louisiane l'Utah intensifie donc le
contrôle sur internet mais les
entreprises de réseaux sociaux
vont-elles se plier aux exigences des
nouvelles lois qui requiert la
vérification d'âge et il n'y a-t-il pas
le risque qu'elle quitte le marché de
l'État
le site canadien de pornographie pornhub
visé par une loi sur la vérification de
l'âge des utilisateurs a décidé de plier
bagages de l'Utah plus d'accès du tout
Jordan demeure optimiste que les réseaux
sociaux trouveront une solution ou loin
Netflix
depuis que ses parents lui ont interdit
l'accès aux réseaux sociaux les
résultats scolaires de Lydie se sont
améliorés
il s'est remise à jouer de la clarinette
elle pense pouvoir d'ici quelques années
avoir un téléphone intelligent et
retourner sur les réseaux sociaux de
façon responsable en attendant et là ce
message pour les adolescents de son âge
l'Utah se donne jusqu'à la fin de
l'année pour finaliser la loi et pour
donner le temps aux entreprises de
réseaux sociaux de s'y conformer